hey hey son meine Frage an dich ist
hattest du schon mal was mit
Elten ist das geil wei warum so
großartig ist ne also ich muss muss mir
echt mal Gedanken machen wie ich mit
Elten umgehe weil ich war gestern bei
hier ab 4 beim MDR und da hat ein
Anrufer genau dieselbe Frage gestellt
aha M M M erwischt nein ich hatte noch
nie was mit Elten Elon ist verheiratet
hat zwei Kinder und wir verstehen uns so
weil Elon ist ein dufter Typ er ist
riesenkumpel hat nur blödsinne im Kopf
ist wie so ein erwachsenes Kind und
macht aus seiner Seele auch nie eine
Mördergrube ist ich liebe ihn er ist
eine Knutschkugel und nur weil wir uns
die ganze Zeit schmusen und busseln
heißt es nicht dass wir dann nach der
Sendung miteinander in die Kiste steigen
nein wir sind einfach obergute Kumpels
und können uns in diesem Haifischbecken
der Medienwelt aufeinander verlassen und
das ist
toll